we got a look at the new Star Trek sort
of the ship we got a look at the ship
but I mean it's already causing a lot of
drams yeah because it does obviously
look very very different and it is not
an enterprise it's not the enterprise at
all it's called the USS discovery NCC
1031 catchy which also me and we also
find out the name of TV shows gonna be
Star Trek discovery abbreviate to STD
haha I feel like what the thing is in
America they call it VD alright and then
I think they've gone from VD straight to
STI whereas in the UK it's always always
been sexually transmitted diseases STD
sexually transmitted discussed want to
be the first person say this new star
trek is worse than STD first stop it no
give her a chance I'm sure it's gonna be
excellent they had a big panel it was
quite disappointing actually because if
we were hoping to find out stuff on the
new Star Trek wouldn't get any caste or
anything but we did find out that it's
going to be set in the prime universe so
not the JJ Abrams alt timeline universe
which is quite cool and the ship itself
was dessert this is quite cool I've done
some digging everyone's recognizing it
like Ralph McQuarrie designed a
prototype ship that looks very much like
this back in the 70s for a star trek
movie that ended up getting canned Ralph
McQuarrie then went on to basically
create the look of Star Wars Oh which is
really cool and this is what the
discovery actually looks like it looks
like his old concept art for what he did
for star trek back in the 70s which
isn't it cool so people are trying to
figure out where discoveries going to be
set we're gonna find out more in January
but did you guys watch the teaser what
did you think I saw a bit of it I'm
always kind of I'm in an out with Star
Trek it's sometimes I watch it and I'm
like yeah this is great and but a lot of
times I'm just like it's the pacing of
it that kind of like I'm not always on
board I have to be in a specific mood to
really enjoy Star Trek whereas something
like Star Wars I can get on board with
straight away because you view doesn't
kind of me but like Federation and they
just want ya unity having said that I'm
in the mood for something a little more
effect flavored to watch yeah and that's
my kind of lens that I'm seeing this
through so like yeah I'm excited about
it and I'm always willing to give you an
opportunity I do like Star Trek well the
guy who's actually writing it and is I
think the co-creator is Brian fellow who
Dave you're watching voyager at the
minute this guy's written a bunch of
voyager bunch of deep space 9 do you
think he can put his put his mark on a
new trick that's its kind of concerning
Spanish because much i love Voyager I'm
like going through all the Voyager again
I kind of in the mood for like a
grittier Star Trek i know i said before
i'd like nutella cleanser but since then
you did pushing daisies admittedly not
the gritty looking for little bit I
Devers come down but he's also Darnell
Hannibal pretty grainy american gods and
the first trailer for that looks gritty
gritty yeah if it's if it's a Star Trek
where I'm gonna see like it looks like
an early design the ship so i'm
anticipating that listed at war with the
Klingons if i see some badass like
federation troopers getting getting
gritty in the trenches with some
Klingons their batlets and stuff sounds
vaguely formula anything it's that I
could be sexual you just add an extra
like battle to the end of end of a word
yes a star trek I'd be into it bridgie
I'm trying to I'm trying to do it want
to get pretty with it no no no no